intelligent indestructible and with no
humans on board these sailboats are
plotting their own course through the
waters of San Francisco Bay
this guy gets his way soon there will be
hundreds of them trawling the oceans for
data this is Richard Jenkins and he's
someone who likes a challenge
[Music]
here is trying to break the world record
for land sailing in 2009 they're
interested in 116 miles an hour which I
thought was a low bar and I could do it
maybe a year and it was actually
anything but easy instead of one year it
took Jenkins a decade of toiling and
deserts around the world but break the
record he did
clocking just over 126 miles per hour in
his own custom-designed vehicle the next
challenge was a nod to Magellan with a
modern twist occurred to me that nothing
has ever gone around the world on man it
was kind of one of the last great
records to get so Jenkins set out to
build a robotic sailboat capable of
circumnavigating the globe in 2013 he
sent the world's first unmanned vessel
across an ocean-going from San Francisco
to Hawaii where she called it the honey
badger doesn't give a [ __ ] it just plows
or anything and somewhere amidst all
that he found time to start a new
business
[Music]
based in this former aircraft hangar in
Alameda California Jenkins company sale
drone has already raised ninety million
dollars from investors and here's what's
got those venture capitalists so excited
a twenty strong fleet of autonomous
seaworthy drones who put the shark faces
on them that was me last week and I just
freehand of that powered only by the
wind and Sun these GPS guided BOTS can
survive at sea for months at a time
bristling with sensors scientific
equipment and cameras they beam back
real-time data and images via satellite
from the ocean surface these two
vehicles on their way back from seven
almost eight months boy okay okay ten
thousand miles where did they go dance
the Eckert or Pacific and flooding El
Nino effects on the equator right you
wanna know it looks like this is the
camera the years on a real-time camera V
and there it is there's a picture from
equatorial Pacific race and sunny it's
always sunny
[Laughter]
right now sale drone is busy prepping
for a new mission a 2,000 mile
round-trip to an area of Pacific Ocean
known as the white shark cafe great
whites come to this remote spot to hang
out for months at a time and scientists
have spent decades wanting to know why
we're working with Stanford University
to take these vehicles and literally
follow the sharks to the cafe to
understand literally what they're doing
there is using food as a reproduction
non really nice the drones are ideal for
missions like this they're much cheaper
than large research ships and can
collect many different types of data pH
chlorophyll humidity radiation wind
speed Direction temperature the list
goes on we measure everything you can
possibly measure near the surface of the
ocean
and data like this sheds light on
something that affects everyone
the weather
there really is infinite use for more
accurate weather and climate data so big
focus for us this year he's deploying
drones into the hurricane field to us to
find out how strong they're gonna be and
where are they going to land and the
impacts of that information is huge so
for insurance risk financial markets and
then for people safety on an unmanned
craft hurricane-force winds would shred
a conventional sale so instead the
drones harness the wind using the hard
vertical wing adapted from Jenkins land
sailing days when wind passes over an
airplane wing it produces lift in this
case the wind produces thrust that moves
the sail drone forward jenkins invented
a tail with a small adjustable tab to
control this force it stops the wing
from spinning out of control and lets
the robot make snap sailing decisions
everything about the craft is 100% salt
water proof and submersible
[Music]
today I'm hitching a ride to see rich
deploy two of his drones to the white
shark cafe there's not much wind so
they're given a tow into San Francisco
Bay before being released it's enough
wind Haven Aspen starts telling me just
of the city and this is where we
normally let them go as soon as they're
released
they're on foot autonomous mode you guys
have gone 200 thousand nautical miles
without a incident yeah we've had the
drones operating for four years now and
not a single scratch on the vehicles and
nobody's ever phoned it in is like a UFO
where some sailors like what the hell
are these things do they behave really
predictably and safely around ships and
there are animals that come up and check
them out and yep now we've got some
really cool pictures so there's a
spotted first seal jumps on for ride up
in the Chukchi Sea about 65 degrees
north and hung out there for six hours
these drones have a two-week journey
ahead of them before they make their
sharp rendezvous and soon they'll be
part of an even bigger fleet want to get
a thousand drawings within three to four
years and that gives us full global
coverage so we have as much or better
date of Nations that we currently have
in the land and that will transform our
understanding of our planet
[Music]
thanks for watching and if you want to
see more hello world click on the link
to subscribe